hello my name is Lavenham I'm a student
of electrical engineering and manifestly
in physics so just wanted to know how
could I switch over to a career in
physics from Abaddon electrical
background yes so to start a car and
physic you you have to begin with a PhD
with a desease and so you were to to
apply to to a supervisor for start to
start apparently and so we have to
convince survive either the laboratory
that you are motivated and so that you
know a lot of seeing on technical aspect
of physics you you are also you have to
want to walk on the more fundamental
aspects and finally when will be after a
PhD you own the good way to to continue
in this session in physics